what in the world is dad this is dopey
well where did you find it
it followed his home we found him in the
jungle
he's a brontosaur oh yes I I can see
that can we keep him we're but I could
train him Wow
kick his legs out from under him and
holler sit I'm not sure that do it how
are you gonna feed him Holly oh he'll
eat anything he'll leave everything
there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock
[Music]
hey it's episode 90 yeah this is an
interesting one I've been wanting to
cover this one for a while you were
right and we were actually gonna do this
one last week
and we've been talking about this was
the one we were gonna do last week but
then you know we had to do the original
night sucker because that dude got
caught yes what are we gonna call this
show what I'm gonna call it that's what
well I was having a hard time because
I'm gonna have to explain yeah you told
me about this you wanted to do this like
a long time ago like I used to have one
of those mysteries and the unexplained
kind of books yeah and you were like oh
yeah and you were like fascinated with
this one or two particular stories in
there yeah well there's actually a whole
section in the book was a chapter on
this subject yes and it had dozens and
dozens of stories from I think the 1800s
in the early 1900s yeah about guys
finding toads in rocks or in lumps of
coal and who and find and weird like
pterodactyl dinosaurs right yeah and I
was just in this and these were
evidently featured in newspapers of the
time yeah and I was wanting to know if
there was anything to this it was weird
because it was a very popular trend at
the time like soon I didn't realize
until I started looking into this yeah
but then I was like well he wasn't you
want to call it I said well we'll call
it like 40 in archaeology because you
know Charles fought in the 40 yeah but
nobody knows him nobody knows what that
is though right well yeah but that's
what it's called it was called and then
I was like well I want a couple more I
want to talk about the frogs I want to
yak tall I was like I need a couple
other things to round the stuff out so
we kind of decided to do naturalistic or
pseudo archaeology that has been used to
support creationism because then I can
kind of narrow it down a little bit
right I mean mostly on talking about
frogs on the road but I got so glad
cause something like toads and rocks or
toads in the halls and something because
if you see 40 in archaeology and modern
people don't know what the hell that is
so you can't it's not a good tagline you
know we'll put that in but this was just
it yeah this is the topic you wanted to
do for a long yeah like what I started
doing it's kind of one of those topics
that once you start looking into it like
there's huge rabbit hole yeah all this
interrelated weird [ __ ]
yeah back in the old days you know most
people heated their homes with coal
they bought lots of coal and they'd have
these reports of throwing lumps of coal
in a fire and a frog jumping out the
flames right toad or a horned toad or
that's usually frogs and then they pull
a lump of coal out and it would be
cracked in half and you can see a
perfect little frog pocket and yeah and
the lump of coal as if the coal had
formed around the frog and the Frog had
been in there for millions of years
right and was still alive said that
right yeah this is like a really weird
very specific thing so like I said we're
kind of gonna go into that this is kind
of a weird topic but Thomson wanted to
do some for a long time because of a
book that he had when he was a kid and
he found it really fascinating before we
get to all that let me do the shout out
to the news stories and all that regular
stuff first shine I want to do why I
usually talk about my book the faceless
villain as I said I'm still working on
volume 2 hoping that I have it out by
June but we'll see how it goes it's you
know it's a lot of work and I'm kind of
getting behind but you know it'll be
summertime anyway so keep an eye out for
that if you haven't seen our latest
movie review it was Dagon yeah Stuart
Gordon very popular and we're trying to
get this movie some more love because I
really really really like this movie and
I feel like it's not that appreciated
yeah cuz it came out much later than
most of his other stuff and it never got
a theatrical release in the US yeah I
went to go try to get Dagon on blu-ray
because I wanted a blu-ray copy of it
and none are available but there's a
company going to do a blu-ray release
it's a collector's edition blu-ray
release with a bunch of extras and I
think it's gonna be remastered it's
coming out July 25th of this year of
2018 they're already accepting
pre-orders I may put in a pre-order for
that I would love to have that on
blu-ray
yeah that's an often maybe that's a
really good movie seeing it again you
know makes you want to own it and I want
to I want to you know get some
behind-the-scenes info on it you know
yeah I'm kind of curious about that like
I said it doesn't really get much
attention which is a shame it's really
good
there were evidently some region B
blu-ray release
which I was what Germany or it's
something yes yeah it's a European well
it might be Spain because that's where I
mean I'm sure it's like a European gonna
yeah cuz I think that was the only place
that I had a theatrical release was
wrong well I want this new release
though the cover looks really cool I'm
excited so I'm just letting anybody know
you know fans if you haven't seen Dagon
go back and watch our review yeah we
should boil it no not really and you can
watch it for free on to be TV it's a
really good Lovecraftian or yeah and
also be sure to check out our dazzling
calm slash 13 o'clock and we have shirts
and a tote bag check out our patreon
page if you would like to give us a
donation or you can go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast at wordpress.com
and there is a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation just like these three
wonderful people that Eric and I know
I'm pronouncing this wrong I pronounced
it wrong before yes jamming Damon yeah
yes and Ciaran yeah they have all three
of them have been given us PayPal
donations in the last week
yeah and Eric and shame and gave the
same amount they were pretty heavy heavy
yeah right guys thanks guys that was a
that was a very very much appreciated
much person donated all donations are
appreciated thanks cure but Eric and jam
and man we're impressed thank you very
much yes that was very very nice of you
guys yeah all right so before we get to
the main topic let me do our little news
stories i couldnt really find anything
that was like archaeologically related
really news bring in the news never had
am I gonna do dancing yes you forgotten
on everybody I'm gonna keep that and I'm
gonna play that I can do it better than
that you just okay so now short notice
I'll have to get you when you're drunk
or something
speaking of being drunk we went out this
Saturday night we hadn't been out in
several weeks yeah so we had a very good
time it was very fun yeah even though it
was thinking of my own dancing on car
yeah yeah I actually got on top of my
car yeah you know the driveway and dance
yeah we got my car well the neighbors
were watching yes playing that was death
and wrong yeah it was a cover of Vogue
the cover of the car started dancing and
then climbed up the hood of the car and
is on top of the car crushed it all in
but you know I just open the door smack
smack yeah we've had a pop back out you
know the neighbors were abused
[Laughter]
yeah they see this at the club they know
[Laughter]
so the news stories I just these are
like just three funny ones that I found
from like a news of the weird site or
something like that I don't know like I
have heard of this [ __ ] before but I
don't know how many of you guys have
heard of it so in 2010 there was this
book that came out called the boy who
came back from heaven and it was it was
a kid and he was in a car accident yeah
and he what company was a quadriplegic
and he allegedly told his dad that he
saw heaven and he met Jesus and the
other kind of stuff and his dad was like
coaching yeah and I wrote a book about
that [ __ ] yeah okay well five years
later that kid came out and said no I
made it all yeah yeah hey mom they had
him on The Oprah and all kinds of the
morning talk shows that we have here in
the US yeah it was everywhere
I don't even pay it down to that kind of
[ __ ] and I stole something out for the
forum for any of our forum listeners you
know like Australia UK India anything we
we have these day time morning type talk
shake them they're damn they're that
well here I don't know what the deal is
television is a dying medium even cable
TV it's just dying if you look at the
age demographics of who's watching it's
you know 75 and above and it caters to
the lowest common
nominator it's the ultimate in just
stupid [ __ ] is what they have on the
yeah or just stuff that's like now we're
like hey we're gonna show people how to
make pancakes yeah we're gonna talk to
this kid who says he went to heaven when
I had when I had to go back to
Mississippi you know what my dad was
getting sick I actually went to
relatives homes they were watching
television still and it was like going
backwards in time you're like oh my god
yes yeah it was kind of like hilarious
because there's like the people working
on the television stations are in their
early 20s and they're making them like
you say cook a meal okay today we're
gonna have we're gonna cook you know
eggs in whatever you know and I'm
banging myself this poor girl she's got
to wake up in the morning and do this
show to cater to a culture that isn't
hers you know it's a stepping stone for
her to be an intern or something like
that being stoned to the death of
television Brown once described actually
wants to work on YouTube bigger YouTube
show that you have a television show
yeah so this kid was everywhere the
funniest thing to me about this story is
that the kids and this is apparently
their real name their last name is
malarkey that should have been your
first yeah the kids name is Alex
malarkey and his dad the guy who wrote
the book is in Kevin malarkey now even
though in 2015 the kid who had you know
grown up a little bit by then obviously
came out said no I made it all up I
didn't really see heaven I didn't exist
it's all [ __ ] and he told that to
the Guardian in 2015 but now I guess but
I don't know people didn't believe him
or anything like that so now he's
actually filing a complaint against the
books publisher which is Tyndale House
or timed Ale House whatever how you
pronounce it and his he is alleging that
quote any reasonable person would have
realized that it was highly unlikely
that the content of the book was true
I guess a lot of people did not realize
that without reasonable they had changed
your last name to vote to Blarney
if you kidding you people go to Ireland
and go kiss that Blarney Stone don't
kiss that bar I had some Irish friends
when I was in Boston they piss on that
barn stone don't [ __ ] up it don't kiss
it so yeah even though evidently the kid
is not suing his dad even though this is
very interesting apparently the kid
never got any royalties from the book
sale of it dad making money yeah off of
his crippled child yeah I mean is there
anything lower than that on a related
related subjects you know what I mean I
had a near-death experience during a
motorcycle wreck I don't know if it's
real man but it did I did have that
stereotypical kind of like tunnel of
light it was mine was a little bit
different and then being surrounded by
kind of like these angelic being type
people that know you and you know I had
that experience I don't really mock that
experience I don't have any proof
whether or not it was real or not it's
people were saying that you know it's
the hallucinations of a dying brain I
don't know
seem real to me but the thing is that
that didn't happen to this kid he's made
it up you just say yeah well and
actually he's kind of alleging that his
dad just damaged although he's not suing
his dad and he's just suing the
publisher saying hey the publisher
should have known that this was crap and
Roy shouldn't have published it in the
first place because like I said
evidently this kid didn't get any
royalties out of this even though I'm
sure that that book sold like a
bajillion copies I remember it being on
all the [ __ ] morning shows like you
said I remember being on the bestseller
list and all that other kind of stuff so
you know I don't know how that's gonna
go I don't know if you guys want to know
about that [ __ ] get our book mountain
closer guys there's a little bit of a
segment where I tell the entire story
about my near-death experience and
actually you know some of the stuff that
I was saw or was shown during my
near-death experience kind of came to
pass and I don't know maybe if you know
just probability would make it have come
to pass anyway yeah and you know we do
have an ability to kind of take the
situation we're in now and estimate or
extrapolate what it's probably gonna be
like in a couple years and yeah it's you
know the human mind can do that but it's
just weird you know when
having it in a near-death context is it
a real phenomenon or do you really go
into the into the astral plane and see
it well I don't know you know I had an
OBE - you know spontaneous out-of-body
experience before that that didn't
involve death I was just falling asleep
and I tell that story also they were
similar but out of the two OBE seemed to
be more air quotes real than NDE just
it's what it felt like it felt like OB
you felt more real than NDE but they
might both be real I don't know I don't
know so I don't know how to mock the
experience I'm just gonna mock the what
this that story made it up I love their
last name is malarkey I'm like this
can't be real yeah I don't know if in
all countries mark it means the same
thing monarchy means [ __ ] in the
United States it's a little bit of an
antiquated term yeah most people still
know don't know what it means right yeah
so I just thought that I was like is
that really their name oh my god you've
gotta be kidding me okay so yeah there's
that sir I don't know that whole
lawsuits gonna go down this you brought
that up and I was able to even plug the
bookie this I yeah we could work in a
plug in somehow two cups of coffee just
woke up you know yeah we were supposed
to record this yesterday we were super
over yeah all right so this one's kind
of funny this was another you know how
about I love these Easter Bunny themed
stories I did one last last time or the
time before last about the woman that
tased her son yeah this actually this
took place at Richland carousel park in
Mansfield Ohio and evidently they had an
Easter Bunny there that all the kids
could come and sit on their lap and sit
like that you know it's just a little
amusement park or whatever and this
woman named LaDonna Huget for a huge
Hewett or something like that 54 years
old March 24th she shows up sits on the
Easter Bunny's lap for seeds to quote
grab him in inappropriate ways okay yeah
I start making a little cup it's awesome
and there is actually somebody filmed it
on their cell phone because I did find
like a very blurry like this
did somebody taken that lap and felt
something the gamer an idea I guess she
then okay this is what the news story
said this was this was from some TV
thing in Ohio but she said she then
moved on to ride a horse on the carousel
yeah
also in ways witnesses described as lewd
she hadn't had it for a while I guess
mr. bunny looked pretty good maybe she
was a furry she's in denial no no
judgment but the funny thing was that
the police chief I love the quote that
he has he says as soon as you think you
hear all I've never heard of somebody
performing those types of acts on the
Easter Bunny music go to those
cemeteries he doesn't know anything
about that
so yeah this woman was arrested for
public drunkenness obviously and I love
the way the goods oh yeah the end of the
story says she is no longer welcome at
the actually those kids nowadays
probably know exactly all right so the
third story this was from the
Minneapolis Star Tribune and this says
there there's an old Dayton's department
store it's a really really big cool
looking building and they've been
renovating it in downtown Minneapolis
and in early April they came across a
mummified monkey Wow
yeah okay and at first they were like
what the [ __ ] is is doing in here but
apparently in the 1960s the store had a
pet department and had a monkey which
right okay most escaped and I guess it
escaped and got into the
air-conditioning ducts and maybe died up
there
oh yeah and so yeah so it has been up
there for all of these years and it's
like mummified so there's a picture of
it I found a picture everybody looks
like like a mummified monkey put that or
they put that I will yeah but there's an
opening a picture of a mummified monkey
yeah so there's not it no where does
like I'm just yeah but they said yeah
the mummy does show an injury to the
abdomen so they think he might have like
walked into an exhaust fan or go
that's what killed him so everybody
starved to death or anything like that
got hurt and I love the the spokeswoman
for the redevelopment team she says we
continue to find pieces of history in
the Dayton's project as we've
redeveloped the building she's like
please let me not find any moment I'd
people in there mummified monkey that's
bad enough
all right so actually that's a pretty
good segue into our main topic like I
said we're talking about what used to be
called back in the old days 40 in
archaeology and a lot of these books
from the era and we were talking about
that kind of came out in the 50s 60s
stuff like that when they were so kind
of calling it that and even up into the
70s like when yeah search of and show
that I was reading I think was from the
late 70s but yeah his stories were
coming from 1900 they were like 20s 30s
1880s around that yeah and this was like
apparently a really popular you know
weird tale because there are [ __ ] loads
of the okay [ __ ] loads yeah when I heard
these stories you know captured my
imagination I was like could these be
real well what's the motive
to make up a story like this and like
some of them involve minors making train
tunnels and breaking into caves that had
what seemingly would be you know
prehistoric creatures you know basically
we're talking about dinosaurs yes small
dinosaurs not big dinosaur the small
dinosaurs and sounded real you know I
mean evidently the lots of witnesses to
it and but I wanted you to look into it
tell me what you found
yeah I don't know just tell a couple
stories I mean the strange thing about
this the phenomena of frogs and toads
it's almost always frogs and toads
sometimes lizards yeah but they are
usually if you guys have seen that like
that Looney Tunes cartoon about the frog
that's in the in the stone and he opens
it can sing and dance and stuff you know
yeah baby that guy yeah it's kind of
like that where's like they'll they'll
open like a rock or they'll open a piece
of coal like you said or LA or like a
tree yeah and then they'll be like a
little frog like sealed in there yeah
like it grew around it like it grew
around it the rock formed around around
I'm not really sure it seems like the
fad for this type of story kind of
started in the Victorian era for some
reason that was a huge rage in the
Victorian era an era for this kind of
story and I kind of thought because in
later years from my understanding
creationists started using that you know
to kind of bolster creation hasn't been
a weird way because they're like oh yeah
they're from before the flood they were
put there yeah something like that
stories would not support creationism
know the modern mind but for some reason
in the Victorian lot of them started
coming about like right around the time
that Charles Darwin published On the
Origin of Species so there was kind of a
lot of [ __ ] going on so that maybe a
creationist could say well of course the
earth is not that old
right this rock formed around
surrounding this frog and the Frog could
probably live for a couple years you
know I mean in mud so the mud turned
into stone so you're you know your ideas
about geology are wrong maybe that's
what they're talking that they thought
oh the frogs have been in there for
thousands of moriah years and that's my
understanding when I read the the story
is that when I was reading these stories
I was thinking they were trying to tell
me these rocks have been preserved in
this suspended animation yeah basically
and when they tell the story and then
give the account they describe the Frog
and you're going like damn that that
frog maybe wasn't there for a million
years what kind of frog is this really
happen so most of these stories like I
said now the first ones come from like
the 15th century
okay now that old 1570 yeah and I don't
know why it was just like there was a
trend for these kind of stories now but
there's no Darwin there so there's no
sort of no concept of creationism really
I'm trying to fight Darwin so 15
hundreds and then maybe there's
something to this would gentleman well
according to the 40 and times I guess
named after Charles for it was the same
right he was he was kind of a guy he
liked to collect all kind now a days
they would probably just call a
paranormal or weird mysteries but it's
you know sometimes called 40 and or 40
on earth or something like that just
because ii miss miss Kepler University
yeah in deference to that guy now if you
look on the this phenomena is usually
called toads in the hole just like that
British dish with the egg or whatever
but if you want to see accounts of it
its Wikipedia page is actually called
entombed animals because it's a it's a
big thing so according to 14 times about
210 and tombed animal cases have been
described in Europe North America Africa
Australia and New Zealand since the 15th
century and even people like Ben
Franklin and stuff like that have
repeated these stories you know the
problem with a lot of these stories is
that a lot of emerges like hearsay right
like a guy I'll say you know for an
example in 1865 there was a article in
the Hartlepool Free Press
it says reported that excavators working
on a block of magnesium limestone taken
for about 25 feet underground
in England discovered a cavity that had
a live toad in it now this was in 1865
yeah they did not have any photographs
of it right pretty much all they had was
someone say so right so that's kind of
the problem with a lot of these stories
so they're they're digging through
magnesium limestone is out there yeah
and they found an empty pocket yeah
pocket with a living frog okay so frog
shaped pocket we're not talking about a
big area right like the size it's only
like a little bit bigger than the Frog
okay as though the rock formed around a
and the Frog was a lot yeah where they
were allegedly alive okay now it's a
story yeah like so around the same time
in the 1860s okay so there was an
article in Scientific American and this
is talking about a silver miner named
Moses Gaines and he found a toad inside
of a boulder that was like two feet in
diameter and the same kind of thing it
was like a little pocket he says that
the Frog was three inches long and very
plump in fact
evidently I mean Scientific American
says many well authenticated stories of
the finding of live toads and frogs in
solid rock solid rock are on record okay
now hold on one second at the time that
these stories appear were any claims
made none talking about were they
claiming anything they just I found it
out pretty much that seems to be the
whole thing of it and I'm not like I
said I'm not really sure why there was
such a rash of these types of stories
like the bear they said the Victorians
loved this kind of thing where it's like
there's some miners like chipping away
in Iraq and he's like hey there's a lot
of frog in there isn't that neat well
what's what I find unusual is that if
you're gonna hoax
a story about finding a live frog sealed
inside of a stone that hopes better
support some kind of a claim that you're
making like see it's true
what's-his-name said it's true that rock
isn't very old there doesn't seem to be
any claim made we found a frog it was in
a stone like I said when you first
started talking about it I'm like yeah I
kind of remember vaguely hearing about
that but the more I looked into I'm like
man it'd be like a shitload of these
types of story that's why it's like a
trend for them well that's why when I
read this section in that book was like
an encyclopedia of the unexplained yeah
and they must have had a hundred of them
in that one set there's a [ __ ] ton I'm
going on there's over 200 ooh what the
hell is this about because there were no
claims made yeah it was just like oh
yeah right
and I don't know it's like super weird
and every now and then like like I said
it's almost always a toad or a frog yeah
sometimes though it's a lizard
okay now this happened in 1821 and again
this just turned up in a magazine and
it's like a secondhand account of
somebody saying you know this guy was a
stonemason he's working on a big chunk
of rock that was that had been 22 feet
below the ground and he found a lizard
embedded in the stone he said it was
coiled up in a round cavity of its own
form and that was like the exact
impression of the animal as though it
had around him he said he thought it was
dead but then five minutes later it
started running around uh-huh he said if
he he says quote it soon ran about with
much celerity
I was like look then so he's climbing
they find finds a coiled up lizard in a
little shape well funny I said we have
lots of lizards around our house I've
never seen one actually coil now soon as
they see I just lay out they lay out
flat so they can literally grow solar
panels so they can get all this done but
okay let's say it's coiled up in a stone
and I guess it's in suspended animation
you expose it to the air and after a few
minutes it just kind of wakes up and
yeah
takes off unaffected yeah it's funny
because as the years went on because
there are some accounts of ones in trees
also and it's not always just one
sometimes it's a bunch okay you know
what I mean and there's like they'll be
like in this pocket industry there'll be
like 60 of them in there like little
ones they're frogs and then they can't
figure out how they got in there because
there's no hole there's no air there's
no food they can't figure out how to get
in or out or anything like that
then as the years went on with more
modern building methods and stuff you
started getting stories about ones like
a turtle embedded in a plaster wall yeah
like you know you get ones in like
concrete floors and [ __ ] like that I
mean there was even one I don't even
know what year this was from but Julian
Huxley who quite a famous biologist he
got a letter from a guy who was like a
like a laborer in Devon sure and he said
that he broke up some concrete flooring
to put some pipe in there he had a
sledgehammer and he's like that looks
like a frog's leg so they both bend down
and they look in there and there was a
frog there was there was actually 23
frogs in this concrete floor there were
like embedded in there in a pocket or
spread out I don't know it doesn't this
is just this is a guy writing a letter
to a biologist I guess now it should be
noted that a lot of biologists if it's
even at the time in the Victorian era
were like [ __ ] yeah kind of thing
right because biologists have done
studies of this phenomena even going
back to I believe the earliest one was
maybe 17 11 I want to say but they
definitely did ones later on in the
1800s where they would take poor little
froggies and they would embed them in
rocks like put them in rocks and no air
and no food and
like that and to bury them and see how
long they would live there like now the
ones that were later I think they did an
experiment in 1820s and one that they
did they said now the frogs that were in
limestone they lived about a year but
limestone has pores so they can actually
get some air and some frogs likes even
some desert frogs and stuff like that
can hibernate for quite a long time
right they because the ones they put in
limestone they lived for a year the all
the other ones were dead all the other
kinds of rocks were dead don't want the
frogs that were in other kinds of rocks
the ones at limestone were still alive
after a year but when he put them back
in the limestone and then buried them
again a year later they were dead too so
you know probably year to years that's
and it pretend it depends on the type of
frog as well like I said okay some of
them can hibernate for a long time they
have some kind of you know they have
they have ones that can do that and you
know it has to be in a rock that can get
air to it like that has pores or pockets
I've heard of frogs that you know can
embed themselves kind of in mud a little
bit and they dry out all right yeah
that's oh okay
that's weird that can't happen how long
can one be dried out and live that's
ridiculous yeah it's it's not like a
super long time because like I said some
of those desert ones that can do that
it's usually it'll be like a year a
couple years something like that that's
aggressive
it is pretty it is so you can see how
that how this might have occurred but
it's like you know these kind of stories
of a rock or like a piece of coal which
takes a long time to form you know
forming around a frog and it's still
being alive after all that time yeah
there's just no way there's no way
like I said biologists at the time we're
like there's no way and they even did
some of the experiments to show that
they do think too that some of these
toad-in-the-hole phenomena type stories
were just outright made up they said
that one of the ones was probably done
by Charles Dawson who was quite famous
for probably being the guy behind that
whole Piltdown man brouhaha so yeah so
he probably did ones like that too so it
seems like a lot of these are probably
fake you know it's a lot of scientists
even at the time
we're saying you know one we're not
getting any really proof of this like no
one's sending us anything it's just like
a letter saying hey I saw this that and
the other thing and they're like you
know maybe some of it is hoaxes maybe
some of it is you know people
misidentified maybe they're cutting some
rock and then they see a frog hopping
and they just assume it came out of the
rock right you know [ __ ] like that so I
don't know how accurate a lot of these
are cuz like I said a lot of it just
came from sort of newspaper accounts or
letters written to biologists saying hey
I found a piece of coal with it you know
if they didn't really have any proof of
it I just don't really get why there was
such a fad for this particular type of
you don't really hear this type of mouth
stuff much anymore this is maybe like
the equivalent of making every UFO say
yes maybe it what like I said it just
seemed like there was it was just some
kind of fashion yeah there's more to it
done there's more cases I think we need
to talk a little bit more about I mean
there was one that I remember did you
find the one about them making the
tunnel yeah but that's that's not a frog
that's not a frog that's my that's my
next thing oh is it okay so that's not
time take for a break okay well we're
going to take a break right now and then
we come back we're gonna talk about your
pterodactyl yeah and also I wanted to
talk a little bit about a couple of
other ones especially want to talk about
like the Paluxy river bed and the I can
borrow figures and that kind of stuff
okay because those have definitely been
used in later years - I know support
creationism and stuff like that so we're
gonna take a break right now and we'll
be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back now here is like an
interesting thing that I made a note of
the earth in the early 19th century the
term living fossil was used to describe
this type of phenomena the entombed
animal the frog inside a rock the toad
in the hole whatever and the interesting
thing was that when Charles Darwin bird
on the Origin of Species
he used living fossil to denote you know
something that had lived for a long time
not changing like the coelacanth would
you know the alligators yeah are things
like that so he's like we're something
that hasn't evolved much you know or
changed much over the years so I thought
it was interesting how he kind of took
that phrase which sort of meant
something kind of paranormally and made
it be like an actual evolutionary term
that meant a specific thing but prior to
that it actually living fossil had men
you know because they said well a dead
fossil is once like bones you find
inside the rock and he's when we find
living ones inside the rock that's a
living fossil right but he took that
phrase and turned it into something else
so I thought that was kind of an
interesting thing okay so this next one
that you're talking about and I remember
you telling me about it took me a long
time to find this yeah I remember
reading this because you just told me
the details and I'm like okay well how
do I even google that but I actually did
find it this is back in the day when you
headed by books yeah a lot of those
books aren't aren't really online yet or
the information of the most books yeah
not all of it has made it into the into
the new online world yet so many stories
are being lost it was hard to find this
one that's yeah I mean once I knew what
I was looking for yeah there was a lot
of information about it but I didn't
really know how to approach it because
you go search for it yeah you didn't
really remember I don't remember all the
details right because you just got in a
book like this you know I had the book
like that I have a book like that see
that was like a Reader's Digest one but
I think it had anything like this in it
well I heard this story I was like man
this has something like this must have
happened it sounds pretty credible but
that was you know back in the 90s I read
this yeah and you know the world's
changed a lot since then this story was
actually published in the Illustrated
London News on February 9th 1856 okay
The Illustrated London News is this a
reputable newspaper it
sounds like it is yes mark x you know I
really know now the interesting thing
about this is that it wasn't like
splashed on the front page or anything
like that it sounds like a little story
like a couple paragraphs or go to the
back page or something like that
according to this story in the winter of
night in 1856 there was there were these
workmen and they were building a railway
tunnel and they broke and removed a
boulder that was supposedly Jurassic
limestone this Boulder evidently broke
open and then there was a creature that
kind of stumbled out of it
and started coming toward them it says
it fluttered its wings croaked and
collapsed at their feet did okay it had
a wingspan of ten feet seven inches four
legs with talons four feet legs joined
by a membrane like a bat and a mouth
filled with sharp teeth black leathery
oily skin yeah so they're saying this
was a living pterodactyl it was alive
and it was inside a limestone like
stalactite or whatever yes yeah and they
discovered it where's the body
exactly yeah see the problem with this
was that and I found this really really
good article where it's kind of talking
about this story now this story even
though it just appeared in the back page
of the Illustrated London News or
whatever on this particular day hey
these dudes and France kind of expect oh
that's still alive write what you think
would be like a big deal but really it
only got repeated much later on like in
a lot of paranormal literature okay and
it was also used to support creationism
because you know anything that it's like
Oh dinosaurs are still alive has been
used to support Susan XE so this story
was repeated a lot back in the day yeah
okay usually in in fourteen times you
know paranormal literally because the
story you're telling me is not exactly
the story I remember the story I
remember is that they were knocking down
stalactites
one of them fell freely and they
realized it wasn't really a stalactite
it was the wings of a creature folded up
around itself it started to flutter and
flap like I said croak and it died and I
think they said trying to fly out of the
tunnel
and their explanation of why they didn't
have the body is that when they took it
outside in the Sun it fell apart rapidly
it turned into basically kind of like
little flakes Yahoo and blew away
yeah well this okay now like I said the
story was repeated many times in
paranormal literature this is the
original story okay this is how it
appeared a discovery of great scientific
importance has just been made at Como
some been employed in cutting a tunnel
which is to unite the whatever the
railway lines were had just thrown down
an enormous block of stone by means of
gunpowder and we're in the act of
breaking into pieces one from a cavity
in it they saw emerge a living being of
monstrous form okay this creature which
belongs to the class of animals hitherto
considered to be extinct has a very long
neck and a mouth filled with sharp teeth
it stands on four long legs which are
united together by two membranes
doubtless intended to support the animal
in the air and are armed with four claws
terminated by long and crooked talons
its general form resembles that of a bat
differing only in its size which is that
of a large goose so it wasn't like a
huge rider it was just it was big but
not its membranous wings when spread out
measure from tip to tip three metres 22
centimetres that's about 10 feet 17
inches its color is livid black its skin
is naked thick and oily its intestines
only contain the colourless liquid like
clear water I'm reaching the light this
monster gave some signs of life by
shaking its wings but soon after expired
uttering a hoarse cry this strange
creature to which may be given the name
of living fossil and that's all in caps
has been brought to grey where a
naturalist well-versed in the study of
paleontology immediately recognized it
as belonging to the genus Pterodactylus
an ass which many many fossil remains of
which have been found among the strata
which geologists have designated by the
name lieth or leus the rock in which the
monster was discovered bones precisely
to that formation the deposit of which
is so old that geologists dated to more
than a million years back the cavity in
which the animal was lodged forms an
exact hollow mould of its body which
indicates that it was completely
enveloped with the sedimentary deposit
that that was the exact story as it was
first published that's so cuz that's the
oldest one that's that yeah that's here
is I just I heard a reboot of that yeah
because like I said it's been
we you know re-engineered and rewritten
and the details have changed over the
years because it was published in a lot
of 40s where's this body where's the
spot right exactly okay so here's this
bottom of the mystery and this I've read
a really good article about this and
they said the problem is that to modern
sensibilities they're like when this
story came out yeah the way it was
written they didn't expect anyone to
think it was real what really the title
of this story when it was first
published
you know the headline was very like a
whale as in a whale of a tale too big to
swallow okay also another clue was that
the latin name that they gave to this
creature Pterodactylus uh NOS a NOS is
latin for duck in french duck is canard
which means a hoax a hoax okay so they
said now Victorian people would have
understood that okay and write it and
said oh good one so it's an inside joke
yeah it was like an inside jokes they
said the problem is that over the years
knowledge of Latin was lost knowledge of
Victorians their love of puns was asked
cultures change the culture has changed
so seriously that it was actually taken
seriously they said when this was
published you know obviously we should
said it was on a back page just like two
paragraphs right it's like you know if
they really found a live pterodactyl
that [ __ ] would be all over every
newspaper anywhere
they're like so they didn't expect any
of the readers to take that seriously it
was just like a funny little rifle of a
store in the version I heard came along
later when people rise seriously they go
worse the body over the body blew away
it dried out quickly but anyway yeah so
you know that's kind of where that came
from and then you know you can see how
later on as knowledge of that got lost
like I didn't know what that Latin word
meant they didn't know there's there's a
similar kind of subject or topic that
maybe one day we should do a show on
that sounds like there may be something
to it evidently the Smithsonian
Institute back in the 1800's was
collecting skeletons from like Native
American cultures and Native American
artifacts
every now and then they'd come across
the barrier in turned body of a Native
American like chieftain or warrior that
would be like seven or eight feet tall
with two rows of teeth don't know I
remember hearing something about that we
should probably do a show about that
because I remember you saying and then
the body would have vanish and they
blamed the guy who who was the head of
archaeology of the Smithsonian's dude
they were blaming him for Kiefer causing
these giant skeletons to vanish because
he thought that would undermine the idea
of kind of like the racial superiority
of the Caucasians right he didn't want
non khakha swords to be thick to be
bigger
yeah I don't know if this is all hoax
and everything right up yeah but that's
that we gotta dig into that yeah I think
that's what ends up happening with a lot
of these like paranormal type stories
and stuff like that you know that end up
in these books later on they just repeat
it over and over but this one like I
said they're pretty sure the way it was
written people that kind of know about
the literature of the time their
Victorian sense of humor
would have known immediately yeah that
that was not real and another thing that
you wander it makes me wonder some of
these stories about the double road
teeth Giants so maybe they started off
as tails like this right yeah that's
what's kind of like difficult about like
it unless you have something in front of
you that is obviously real you know so
you can't just take someone's hearsay
you can't just say I found this in that
and oh I don't know what happened to it
I lost or whatever that's like you know
I'm sorry maybe that did happen to you
but unless you got but this story it
should be noted too that the way they
described this so-called pterodactyl er
you know pterosaur is nowadays now they
know that that's not what they look like
and they didn't stand on four legs they
didn't look like what they're describing
bro is it what they're describing there
is a fictional monstrous right the you
know that turned up in like Arthur Conan
Doyle stories and stuff it's yes I'm
looking calm yeah it's supposed to like
they're like but nowadays they know that
that they don't
look like that now you know like I said
the way they're describing it and the
way they're describing it is not he was
super super huge I mean ten feet that's
pretty big but they do have like fruit
bats and [ __ ] like that better
pretty big yeah but those are furry so
you know I don't even think this is a
case of they just mistakenly were like
holy [ __ ] they saw a big bat and Greg
thought it was Tara - totally hoax story
yeah it seems like this story was just
completely fabricated we're gonna start
to finish and then later on got repeated
rules but yeah so that was another
pretty common thing to living pterosaurs
and like I said anytime that you get and
that's why I used at the beginning of
the show I used to clip from land of the
loss because anytime you have evidence
that dinosaurs and people are living at
the same time or that dinosaurs are
still alive for some reason creation is
jump on that because they think that
that supports young Earth Creationism
reason and [ __ ] like that like dinosaurs
that wasn't a long time ago right humans
human beings Road dinosaurs for yeah all
the reason why they live side by side is
dinosaurs were all vegetarian yeah it's
all [ __ ] that crazy young earth
gracious
yeah they're so yeah dinosaurs used to
be vegetarians and we rode on the
machiya there were our friends and all
this a little broken and what they made
for us we we just happen to have all
bodies haven't evolved by accident and
yeah so trial and error yeah so another
thing that is usually used to support
creation as a murder are the very famous
akamaru figures I don't know anything
about these okay educate there's about
33,000 of these little things though
there are little ceramic figurines about
yay big summer a little bit bigger
now these allegedly were found by this
german fella named Valdemar Jules Road
I'm sure I'm pronouncing that wrong that
was in 1944 and he supposedly found them
in the Mexican city of Aachen Baro
now there were a [ __ ] ton of these
figures some of them what do they look
like think some of them look like
dinosaurs okay so the reason that
creation is like to point to that or
paranormals like two points and saying
look dinosaurs were still alive you know
just a couple thousand years ago because
ancient people were see
yeah the contention is that Asian people
were seeing dinosaurs in front of their
faces and then ranking these little
figurines of fact well I'm going to tell
you one thing though there is something
to be said for that a lot of these
mythological creatures that the Greeks
made up or the result of fine a dinosaur
bone so they won't really like the right
you know the dinosaurs that we know
they're not the famous ones but the you
know the ones that just were kind of
like the size of the shape of kind of a
horse they'd find something like that
and go this is a cyclops yeah or they
mix two things together because it was
all coming out of the same side of the
same hill and they would like go yeah
this is a sphinx well so they really
were finding weird bones yeah and you
you know you would extrapolate because
it's very hard when you find a skeleton
especially of an animal you're not
familiar with to kind of imagine what
that would look like when it had flesh
on it right you know Mary could they can
make up all kind of factions he did see
dinosaurs but when they found them they
caught they thought they were gods okay
yeah so the story with this one goes
this guy he was a German immigrant he
lived in he was living in Mexico and he
was evidently he says this is the story
he stumbles upon the figures while he's
riding his horse and he hires a local
farmer he's like I'll give you I think
he was said I'll give you a peso for
every one of these you bring me because
it's like wow this says that ancient
people saw dinosaurs they were making
these little dinosaurs okay so for every
one of these dinosaurs I find Wow I'm
gonna go God work finding as many of us
a can exactly and he eventually ended up
with 30 2013 yes and you know so they're
claiming that ancient people made these
and you know that they were seeing
dinosaurs and [ __ ] like that the problem
is that obviously when reputable
scientists yeah looked at these they're
obviously not old
that was another he start scratching on
rocks yeah it's you know it's like
according to this one guy he's like look
there they're trying to say that there
are thousands of years old and [ __ ] like
that they're like obviously not it's
like they're none of them were broken
right he's like if some of
were broken they were only like broken
in half like somebody tried to make it
look like they were oldest driver he's
like you know real archaeologists when
you're fine like potsherds and stuff
like that it's like we just find pieces
of [ __ ] you don't you know it's very
rare to find like a ceramic thing that's
still in one piece right that doesn't
have [ __ ] missing off it he's like these
are really really they look really nice
none of a hardly any of them are broken
babies have any soil
I guess there's meaning no abrasions
they're nothing let me guess they look a
lot like the things you would buy at a
tourist trap yeah yeah the handmade so
yeah basically even though I think the
guy that supposedly like gave it and so
you can see some of them in various
museums like around the world and stuff
and they're you know I I don't think the
museums are like yeah these are proof
that and they had like a peoples existed
with Dinosaurs they have like commonly
depicted stuff like Stegosaurus and yeah
- is that a lot of the dinosaurs
quote-unquote don't really look like
dinosaurs really looks like they said a
lot of them had like mammal feet okay
they're not all dinosaurs like some of
them are little people that are they
depicting to dinosaurs stand side by
side that lived into different eras - oh
you know what I don't mention that but
yeah they're like wait a minute this was
and this was a Cretaceous it doesn't
work well yeah because I think and I use
these in dinosaur movies all the big
ticket dinosaurs all right at the same
time even though that wasn't right well
I used to think that when I was a little
kid because I used to be really into
dinosaurs but when I was 6 or 7 years
old you just say oh t-rex and dinosaurs
and all the really cool ones they all
lived at the same time but that's some
billions a Stegosaurus fighting a diver
dog before the dinosaurs almost yeah
yeah sometimes there were millions of
years I mean obviously these are not old
even though I have seen some creationist
websites and I hope you guys appreciate
because I don't really like going on
creationist websites because I can't
because the crazy gives me a headache
of some creationist sites still use
these as proof that ancient people
actually saw dinosaurs even though like
I said a lot of these knives with people
would they they have like little
elephant type feet and they're like
little mammal II looking feet they don't
like cap they don't
they're cute and everything like they're
cool little figures and everything but
the problem is that why can't we just
appreciate them as like hey the local
the industrious local people made these
when this German came I'll give you a
peso for it everybody's my god right
yeah and the farmer was like yeah
Bella's friends and more like little
dudes and stuff too but this yeah
probably liked it though cuz he probably
made money with too you know showing
these things off yeah making a name for
himself so he was probably in on it yeah
and then okay so since we're talking
about humans and dinosaurs existing at
the same time let's talk a little bit
about the the so called Paluxy
footprints these are they put in the
Paluxy River bed in Texas this is it
actually a very legitimate
archaeological site there are dinosaur
footprints in this riverbed alright this
is this is legitimate scientists of all
is you know they've done lots of studies
of it there's tons of pictures of it all
then obviously dinosaur footprints in
this riverbed problem is but there are
also some other footprints that
creationists say are human and that
they're from the same time period as the
dinosaur footprints why why do they say
the same because they're at the same
level and they seem to be side by side
yeah I think I've seen this case before
yeah it's not really what it appears to
be there's a ways around that it's not
yeah the problem is that even though so
like I said creationists are using this
and are going to say look people and
dinosaurs walked a deal it was Fred
Flintstone and Dino they were walking
right next to each other head whatever
it was sure you're a young earth
creationist and you're in the audience
not making funny or anything just saying
that if human beings lived side by side
even with the smallest of dinosaurs back
in those days with the technology that
humans had access to humans would be
toast yeah even small even small Raptors
4 foot 5 foot tall Raptors would tear
humans apart yeah this couldn't survive
next to him humans couldn't stop at the
food chain yeah humans couldn't even
live in the Americas until the short
straw States bear bear when it
yeah and the short-faced bear would have
just been annihilated by dinosaurs
that's how badass dinosaurs in the short
base short-faced bear were so humans
could not live side-by-side with
dinosaurs yeah dude look at the food we
are these insects would probably kill
you yeah because there were cockroaches
that were nearly a foot long back then
and they had dragon foot they had dragon
dragonflies with nearly six foot
wingspans that could take a bite out of
you the size of an apple think about
that for a while
the bugs would kill you okay I mean what
do you think about it human beings yeah
we're smart and everything we can build
[ __ ] which is pretty much the only thing
we have going for you because other than
that we reins would not furless yes
little meat bags brains would not help
you in the dinosaur era I don't think
only size armor weapons did yeah it was
an arms race of biological arms right
yeah yeah so anytime I see this [ __ ]
about humans and dinosaurs in
side-by-side now the problem with a lot
of the quote-unquote human footprints
found at the Paluxy River bed okay they
know for sure that some of them are fake
people that locals have carved them you
know to either sucker and tourists or to
you know support creationism or whatever
the ones that are not faked are
obviously not human even though they're
smaller they're like okay
they're like here's the problem the
dinosaur ones that they know our
dinosaur ones they're like you can tell
how much the dinosaur weighed by how
Detailers the footprint is in there
they're like some of the human
footprints are as deep as the dinosaur
ones even though the dinosaur probably
outweighed the person right yeah I'd
like do you extend to outer times
so they're like so obviously that's
wrong also some of the human ones
quote-unquote they're like if you look
at them very closely some of them have
toes sticking out the side or like a
claw mark in the back and they're like
so it's obviously a smaller dinosaur
it's not a footprint that is like eroded
by the water and makes it look vaguely
like a human shape okay
footprint so as much as creationists
like to tout this although it should be
noted that some of the creationists in
their literature and in their textbooks
and stuff like that because they have
those
have warned other creationist not to use
this anymore as proof of creationism
just because it's been chipped away at
so much
so what them are still using it but some
of them actually do have the presence of
mind to say hey don't use that anymore
because that's been debunked that's kind
of another thing now let's this last
topic I want to get this is I don't know
a great deal about this but this is
something that keeps coming up too
in regards to pseudo archeology and [ __ ]
like that this is a the Moab man or also
called the malachite man I've never
heard of and this was yeah this was
something I just kind of came across
when I was Reacher's research and I
thought it was kind of interesting this
is a bunch of human skeletons and they
were built bulldozing in a mine now the
rock that they bulldoze it out was
supposedly dated from the early
cretaceous period so we which is about
140 million years ago so creationists
are saying oh well these are obviously
humans you know they're young earth
creationists they're saying obviously
the geology is wrong this rock is and as
old as raw as you say and all this other
kind of [ __ ] cuz there was humans in it
now this discovery was originally made
in 1971 and then later on I think in the
90s they they found some more of them
some of the skeletons have actually been
bought
Carl Bao who is a creationist - one of
the ones that still tells the Paluxy
footprints he actually bought the
skeleton to put in his creation Science
Museum as proof that you know the earth
is young and [ __ ] like that problem is
that when legitimate scientists looked
at these skeletons but there are real
human skeletons is that they are not old
they're not as old as the rock all right
you can carbon date him probably yes
they've been carbon dated to between 210
and 1450 years old they're like so these
people were either deliberately buried
like in a ceremonial thing or they were
accidentally buried like in a rock slide
or something like that cuz there's a
bunch of them these are not tatius
people these were just poor guys that
were buried in this particular cave or
this particular type of rock or were
buried but like I said by a rock slide
and then were found later many years
later but yeah they
they said they're only between 200 and
1500 years old that's all they are so I
guess we're kind of getting to the end
of the show this time off had a bunch of
different directions but it was kind of
interesting
yeah I'm actually kind of glad that yeah
you brought this up because it was kind
of a weird Rapids we got down to the
bottom of the pterodactyls story yeah we
know where that came from
yeah did we ever actually really get
down to the bottom of the Frog stories
not really because like I said most of
the accounts of them were secondhand
right or there was no corroborating
evidence it was usually just like people
saying hey we were working in this mine
or we were you know drilling this rock
yeah and a frog jumped out it's kind of
hard to merriments say that it's not
possible yes cannot survive at least two
experiments done right one in the 1720
18-hundreds where they attempted to put
a rock you know put a frog inside a rock
and see if it would live and none of
them did now these suppose that frogs
that jumped out of the rock no one ever
came forth with that individual frog and
presented it saying this is the Frog
yeah it's like so you can't really
identify the species all progress that
I've ever seen and I'll put in I'll
probably put it in the YouTube video
there is a photograph of a rock it kind
of looks like a geode actually but I
don't think it's a gia but it kind of
has that similar kind of look and it's
got like like a hole cut out it's like
cut in half and then there's like a
little mummified dried-up frog in there
but the thing is it's like that could be
faked yeah you get a dried-up mummified
frog I'm putting my demo back they've
gone back of the Windows house you put
that next to a geode go deep that was in
there right yeah and and a similar thing
happened it seemed like when there was
such a such a fad for this kind of shed
some people tried to like put it in
museums that like look at this thing was
founded like naturalist came forever
like don't put take that out of Museum
[ __ ] no by the stories of frogs
coming out of coal that I couldn't
really fight finding no it was mostly
just it was rocks
lime stones I remember some of them Java
I remember some of the stories said they
jumped out of the fireplace or they
jumped out of the furnace there might be
stories like that but I couldn't really
for that
I think now that I'm looking at it
though I would say that the stories
stopped coming big name here ones every
now and then but you don't really like I
said it seems like a lot of them were
around the end of the 19th century there
seem to be kind of a trend you would
think that if this was a real phenomenon
that it would continue up to the present
this saw this frog jumped out of a rock
yeah you know I found it ahead a little
pocket because one of the stories I
remember reading is that they had a rock
and cracked in half when they were
working and a frog jumped out of it they
caught the Frog yeah and they found
inside the Frog perfect indentations and
upper and lower indentation they put the
Frog next to the indentation and he went
right back in there and nestled himself
and that he liked to go back into it and
they said that they checked in his mouth
had been sealed shut and all of his
openings except the nostrils had all
grown shut as if to save water weird
story but I was almost kind of buying it
you know I mean I'm 1716 reading this
[ __ ] and I'm going yeah maybe maybe that
could happen I mean like they said it's
not there are some types of farms like I
said they can hibernate for a long time
they're underneath the deserts and again
it's time you're like why would they lie
[Laughter]
it is it's like sometimes - like the
like the story about the pterodactyl
it's like they weren't necessarily lying
that was just a joke that they didn't
expect anyone to take Syria then just
later on people read that were like what
the [ __ ] they found it turn tackle and
then they started publishing it growing
these paranormal books without really
checking if it was true or not
so it's nothing's lying I mean they
probably thought it was a true story
they heard it from something frog
stories always mystified me because they
gave details but they never made any
claims yeah what is what the oddest
thing about it that I found because
there are so many like little accounts
of it but I'm like why that seems like a
weird thing is usually if you're gonna
hoax a story alright there's a claim
that goes along three for instance I saw
this light in the
guy did this it outperformed agenda
today so therefore it was aliens
therefore there's life on the other
planets right you would think that it
would be something like I found a frog
it was in a rock it would did it
therefore I don't even know what the
claim would be it does seem like a
creationist type of claim but they don't
make but they never say never say
therefore the earth is not old they
never say that not really they never
make a claim yeah they just say we saw
there it is look at that it's just this
amazing the frog jumped out and they
never make the young-earth clang yeah
not until later it seemed like the
stories are paying a bit later but they
started in the 1500s so when I'm
hundreds of years before somebody made
the claim yeah young earth that's what
was so odd about that's what I'm saying
like what a weird thing to make up yeah
but like I said you know that's a hell
of a drug culture is so different like
you know no it's hard to extrapolate
back what it was back that we're
thinking and like what what else was
going on in the culture that might have
inspired that you know maybe there was
some popular novel at the time forgotten
about that had that in it cuz even when
everybody was like oh that's a neat idea
even if you don't know
even with airship sightings okay and
there was some bunch of weird airships
got their work there was a claim yeah
claim was is that flight was possible
right and that airliners and things like
Zeppelin's one were coming yeah and they
did come it was only a matter of time
that yeah there were saplings you know
yeah they called that one look any idea
that yeah they had the ideas and then
but some people were climbing that no
they already exist
yes Zeppelin's already exist we saw him
they threw down an anchor and they can't
they slid down the ask for coffee and
they climbed back up and they left you
guys didn't see it everybody here so I
like your ship stories I find it weird
that they animate they seem held an
airship but they can't even put a coffee
pot on it yeah they have to come down
background and they come I think they
had a strange accent they came from
somewhere else
think about airships stories is that
there's a possibility that a couple of
them might be might be real when the
airship is not really described as being
really fantastic like it was only 40
feet long and only had one guy in it
yeah someday later on in France they had
guys that built them and handle them a
bicycle and then tried to land them near
their local cafe so everyone could see
him yeah that's a forgotten phenomena
but that [ __ ] happened yeah back in
France you know the French were doing
that in the 1800s personal Zeppelin's oh
they call the Zeppelin
they're individual and they actually had
like bicycle chain driven propellers
that they could try pedal this damn
thing and evidently could steer them
there was one French nobleman that could
steer it and land it and he was famous
for I don't remember cause name is all
of top of my head but that do at least a
certain extent did happen so that's not
a super crazy figure it's developed
those later on yeah they don't want to
be crazy to say somebody figured it out
right hand right they had guys that were
like rich nobleman doing their thing I
had ahead of the curve yeah basically
yeah but yeah the frogs from rocks man
weird what were they thinking I'm gonna
make up those lies I don't know that's
what that's what fascinated me about
yeah that's why I'm glad you suggested
it cuz I probably never would have just
black ass you never hear that one
anymore
no it's a yeah that seems to kind of go
muscle literature
so that'll do it for episode 90 gosh
only ten more episodes and we have to do
our special edition 100th episode yeah
yeah that'll be coming up so I hope you
guys enjoyed this kind of rambling
discussion as they usually are remember
if you'd like if you liked the show
remember to Like share subscribe share
with all your friends and give our
Facebook page go to our Twitter or
whatever if you'd like to financially
support the show go to our patreon at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
go to our blog at 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation that
way also be sure to check out our latest
movie review which was Dagon directed by
Stuart Gordon based on the HP Lovecraft
story the shadow over its mouth and also
check out our dazzling zazzle.com slash
13 o'clock and we have shirts and a
t-shirt that you may purchase if you
would like and the battle do it for
episode 90 about 40 in archaeology by
[Music]
[Music]
you